certain provisions under the cares Act
that's the bill that delivered those
1200 dollar stimulus checks and
increased unemployment benefits by $600
are set to expire next month if Congress
doesn't agree on further assistance some
benefits like that enhanced unemployment
will less and it could send tens of
millions of Americans into economic
freefall tens of millions of families
would be directly harmed when they saw
their unemployment insurance benefits
reduced and many more would be harmed
indirectly because the first group of
people when they didn't get their
benefits would spend less money and that
would mean jobs lost and incomes lost
you know in a second-round affects on
throughout the economy so far we've done
a pretty good job of solving a lot of
that in direct effect but if we didn't
extend the Cure's ACT then in addition
to the kovat crisis we would have a much
more normal recession above and beyond
it that would affect just about every
business because as people lost money
they'd pull back their spending um
throughout the economy to understand
what the cares Act could do and couldn't
do if you look at the month of April and
the month of April disposable personal
income went up by more than it's ever
gone up in history because people got
more money from the government at the
same time consumption went down by more
than it's ever gone in history because
people weren't able to safely spend
their money the good news is that it
protected people's balance sheets so
when it's safe to spend the same level
again people should be able to afford to
do so that will help speed up the
recovery of the overall economy but that
will only happen if we don't go over a
fiscal cliff and you know start taking
money away from people again
Democrats have pushed for extending
these benefits but a major source of
hesitation among Republicans is the fact
that some people take home more money
under extended unemployment than they
would if they were working the
Congressional Budget Office estimates
that if the benefits are extended until
January this would be the case for
roughly 80% of recipients I don't think
we should extend exactly what was done
in the cares Act the next phase needs to
be adapted to the economic situation for
example unemployment insurance benefits
could be a little bit less generous next
time we could have more incentive for
people to go to work and reward for them
back on the job so I think you do need
to alter what you're doing based on
economic circumstances but altering and
reforming it is very different from just
allowing it to come to an end as
lawmakers struggled to reach an
agreement over extending the care Zack's
emergency benefits there's now concern
among lawmakers that Mays positive
numbers touted by President Trump as a
stupendous victory for the economy and
his administration will erode enthusiasm
for another big relief package the
economy is starting to recover but it's
starting to recover with a massive
amount of assistance so it's important
that we don't look at the recovery and
say oh we don't need to help anymore in
fact a recovering party's because of the
help we need to continue it and the best
thing Congress could do is make the
magnitude of benefits depend on what's
going on in the economy the unemployment
rate is very high then benefits will be
large if the unemployment rate comes
down then benefits will automatically
scale down with it so making the
assistance automatically adjust based on
what's going on in the economy and how
much it's needed I think would be the
best thing for Congress to do in the
next stage
you